the capper in a closet are you
eat shitty well I gather the Nazis we're
looking for another notch how
did they knock with this in the movie
had it not he's not fine
[Music]
one of my best friends the host of the
podcast podcast please give it up
[Music]
yeah I am the machine I'm nursing one of
the worst hangovers I've ever had in my
life right now so cheers to Ari
the Comedy Central I don't read a lot
oh I'm not I'm not I'm not like a I'm
smart I'm not like a like I'm not good
with facts and stuff like I was talking
to some of the other day and I realized
I'd always thought Anne Frank and Helen
Keller were the same person
like well into my twenties do you know
where I found out at the Anne Frank
House you have any idea what I I went
okay I backpacked through Europe when I
was 22 with these four guys three
lawyers so I can't say their names the
other ones named wheat Joe and these
guys are just nerds the whole
time we were backpacking like you
weren't gonna like the Louvre do you
want to see David doing we should take a
class and learn about how they cut
diamonds when we get engaged
we could have I'm like I the is
wrong with you guys
we're here to bang Swedish chicks that's
it like are you out of your minds and
then one day they're like hey do you
want to go to the Anne Frank House and I
lit up I was like yes and they're
like wow you seem really excited I was
like no we'll get a bag of weed and
we'll laugh our dicks off
and they're like really I go yeah be
here jokes about this girl my whole life
we get a high put a plunger in the
toilet they're like what way I could you
get to go into the house and they're
like yeah you can see the closet they
kept her and I go they kept her in a
closet
are you me like yeah the Nazis
were looking for another how did
they mop with this in the movie how did
the Nazis not fine so I get excited I
get a bag of weed and I'm like I can't
wait to go to the M Franco I'm like
beaming I'm so pumped up on our walk to
the N Frank house in Amsterdam we passed
by a sign that says live sex live sex
live sex flying dildos and I'm like
alright suck a silent dick and Frank
[Music]
we're going to see flying dildos we can
that what you're gonna you're gonna pick
culture or the Anne Frank House I'm
going with culture so I get us tickets
we all go in has anyone ever been to a
live sex show one guy in the back
perfect its aggressive it's a lot
creepier than you'd ever think see
here's the problem with a live sex show
every show you go to elicits a response
when you come to this show you know to
laugh when you go to see music you get
inspired but when you go to a live sex
show the only response is to creep
people out just like oh maybe I'll get
hard
so we go in we sit down it's as intimate
as this without a joint get to know some
of the other fellas like-minded
gentlemen first woman comes up no
fanfare no intro music not even that hot
she's like a sex show six comes up
she definitely has another job like
trust me it's this intimate it needs to
be excuse clothes and she just starts
oil-rig herself just went no listen I'm
not digging the foreplay but total lack
of foreplay looks a lot like a salt okay
and she is going to town and we're
making the same looked at Oh which she
confuses for oh I guess they can't see
and just goes back to performing her
gynecological exam on herself now I have
a problem with silence so I immediately
start talking to her and I'm like do you
speak English
she's like no I was like are you
doing a really good job he's like oh
thank you and I heard you do fine dildos
and she's like no I was like great five
minutes five minutes she does is five
minutes just goes to town herself just I
guess grabbed by the end we're like
awkward like now it's our learning
about the woman's anatomy look after
urethra I think that's amazing she gets
done we give her a golf clap
- girls come onstage and now this girl
was all song no dance these girls are
all dance no song a lot of foreplay
you can't walk backwards in a story like
I had to stop and go ladies ladies we
just watched a woman fist herself like
let's cut to the pink meat okay like
what they're like making out guys and
now I'm the spokesman someone's like can
you get them to hurry it up and I'm like
sure I go you guys do flying dildos and
they're like no I was like okay next and
they're like huh well if we're good
we've seen what you have to offer they
leave then a guy and a girl come out now
this is where it gets creepy I'm not a
huge feminist by believing women's
rights okay and this guy just starts
doing crowd work he's not even
corporator in it's like an improv team
when she's just off to the side like
one of Jeff Dunham's dummies
just he's like ah you guys this by the
way this is exactly what it feels like I
want you to feel it you guys ready to
see me huh you want to see me
this man
it good it's creeping me out and
it's assaulting my morals and I lean
hover to my friends I go we should've
just gone to the Anne Frank House which
this is this guy all because oh don't
bring up and Frank in this room man then
I go whoa him which I was hand
Frank right now so I have to see this
and then he starts arguing me but he's
arguing with me and getting his dick
hard like but gets such enough like he's
like pulling it going oh man don't worry
it gets big I'm like not on my watch it
doesn't and I started heckling his dick
I'm like think about your mom and he's
like hey you body
everybody says sir he's okay
not now man not now I go we should just
go to em Frank and he's like you
and he stormed off and now the lunatics
are running the asylum and I'm their
leader I'm there I'm like the
Rosa Tubman not Rosa Tubman god
damnit
by the way I am neither Rosa Parks or
Harriet Tubman right right right now
right now in heaven Rosa Parks Harriet
Tubman Helen Keller and Anne Frank going
what the is this guy doing to our
names Helen :
I'm their Rosa Tubbs stupid when
I started this time what are you pulling
on high school chant like we put our
hands up by our feet alone we flying
dildos playfellows yeah we want yeah
flying dildos yeah
they send out some girl to calm us down
and we blew her off stage like get the
out bitch we hoped would find
Gillis you heard us now then there's
okay then let's kill this beer
[Music]
I'm hitting it hard as woman comes
out German woman 6 feet tall by high
leather boots
bikers cap medicine bag prop sit on the
stool and goes gentleman's please calm
down I am flying dildos and the place
calls bananas
it looks like the control room in NASA
when Apollo 13 landed like oh we did it
we did it
she goes stop I will need the one
volunteer from the audience and these
assholes look at me like you're up
numbnuts I get up on stage and I
am so excited that I've brought about
change I feel like I've accomplished
something in my life I literally look at
my constituents like you said you want
to change I didn't say that probably but
I was like or whatever I said I'm
Rosa Cobbs Minh and I don't even realize
her putting a handcuff on me and when
the second one goes on I go hey maybe we
should talk about how flying dildos
works like I feel like I'm in the dark
on this one and she is not have like
happy eyes look on her face and sweeps
my legs and like a karate kid' moved and
I land hard I laughed so hard I knocked
the wind out of myself and let me tell
you something about you not to win
that's a real noise just it is
so real and real respects real when you
hear that you're like oh she tears
my pants off me and my dick pops out of
my boxers unprepared gentlemen
I look at my best friend wheat so when I
go poke it back in he's like I will not
be doing that and then the air is
removed out of the room and I hear some
guy go do it and I'm like what I
look up
this woman is straddling my face with a
12-inch black dildo and ex calibers it
into my mouth gentlemen you've a
game-time decision to make what do you
do in that situation do you purse your
lips close your teeth and hope to block
the shot could lose your front canines
or do you acquiesce and open up and let
her go yard in your jaw I chose the
latter
she went eight inches into my throat
just now I'm gagging the winds knocked
out of me my dicks popping out I'm
wiggling like the very last unicorn and
she looks at the guys and says gentlemen
get your cameras and line up to get a
picture with flying dildos these
turncoats
run it up like they're meeting the
Queen they're like I can't wait
and everyone takes a picture with me
ah the point of my story the reason I
told it to you is if you if you ever go
to Amsterdam just go to the M Frank
House thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like first of all don't leave your
shirt all right come before you leave
second of all do you ever go to the N
Frank house oh yeah so I was a I was a
little rattled after the whole flying
dildos experience and but all the guys
in the room thought I was the greatest
guy ever it was like killing in a comedy
club and they I could walk out and
they're all it's three football players
from UCF three French Canadians a dude
from Tennessee and I got from Australia
and my four friends and they're like we
would do anything with you and I was
like well I could use some cheering up
let's go to the Anne Frank House not a
cheerio planet plays so much so we get a
highest giraffe and go to the N
frank house and all I'm doing the whole
time is telling Helen Keller jokes I'm
like I'm like leaning up to him going
like you know she had a dog right and
they're like really I didn't know so
much about em right
I'm like he ran away I know like he ran
away I was like well you would too if
your name was wrong we go into the
kitchen and I'm like oh here's where she
burned her fingers and they're like what
yes you tried to read her waffle iron
and this lady in front of us ha ha ha
mind your piety buddy this lady no I'm
just going to tell you like that's not
the right person
lady turns around goes are you making
Helen Keller jokes are you alright I
realized at that moment that we're not
in Helen Keller's house we're in the end
Frank house and I'm who the she is
and these guys see it in my eyes and 12
dudes fall apart as high as a in a
Holocaust Museum and that is the best
laugh you can have is when you're not
supposed to laugh and I'm putting all
the pieces together like oh I think I
was thinking aunt Sullivan oh yeah
yeah this is the wrong way go what
happen to this girl ha ha ha been
Braille thank you
[Music]